WELCOME TO THE EVENT THIS
AFTERNOON.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
TO HAVE KEN BURNS  AND LYNN
NOVICK  AND THEIR CAPACITY TO
REDUCE DOCUMENTARIES AND
NARRATIVES
>> I HAVE A FEW THINGS TO SAY
BY WAY OF INTRODUCTION.
THE FIRST IS SIMPLY, I CAN
THINK OF NO MORE IMPORTANT
EVENT IN MY LIFETIME, NO MORE
DEFINING EVENT IN THE VIETNAM
WAR AND CONFLICT.
I WANT TO SAY EVENTUALLY WHAT I
THINK ABOUT TODAY IN LIGHT OF
THAT COMMENT. I ALSO TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT THE HEALING
THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE IN
SIGNIFICANT PART AT THIS
UNIVERSITY OVER THE COURSE OF
THE DECADES.
IT HAS HAPPENED SIGNIFICANTLY
THROUGH OUR MAGNIFICENCE
PROGRAM CALLED GENERAL STUDIES.
OUR ENROLLMENT OF MILITARY
VETERANS IS ONE OF THE PROUDEST
PIECES OF COLUMBIA'S IDENTITY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
ONLY IMPORTANT FOR THE GOOD OF
THE COUNTRY, THE GOOD OF THE
WORLD, IT'S NOT ONLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF SOME ABSTRACT IDEA
OF DIVERSITY.
IS A TRULY ORIGINAL IDEA
INHERENT IN THE CREATION OF THE
SCHOOL GENERAL STUDIES THE
TALENTS, CAPACITY, AND ALL
FORMS AND ALL PLACES AND ALL
AGES.
I WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO THE SCHOOL AND
TO PETER AWN FOR THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]THE SECOND PART IS
THE BROADER ISSUE IS THE
MILITARY AND UNIVERSITIES AND
REESTABLISHMENT OF ROTC ON
CAMPUS.
I WAS VERY MUCH IN FAVOR
BECAUSE OF THE STRONG POSITION
I THINK THE UNIVERSITY TOOK AND
HAS TAKEN OVER THESE YEARS AS A
MATTER OF PRINCIPLE ABOUT
POLICIES SUCH AS DON'T ASK
DON'T TELL DISCRIMINATION
LARGELY WITHIN THE MILITARY
THAT WE HAD TO STAND UP TO.
THERE WAS ALSO, IN THE VIETNAM
ERA, A WIDENING GULF BETWEEN
UNIVERSITIES.
THE ACADEMIC WORLD AND THE
MILITARY.
WHICH WAS, TO MY MIND,
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDABLE OF
THAT MOMENT.
OVERTIME, IT HAD TO BE RESOLVED.
WE'VE TAKEN A STEP TOWARDS
THAT.>> THE LAST THING I WANT
TO SAY IS ABOUT THE WAR IN
VIETNAM.
AS WITH ANY DEFINING
EXPERIENCE, IT WAS INTERTWINED
WITH MANY OTHER EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT MOVEMENTS AND CHANGES
AND I'M THINKING ESPECIALLY OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
FEMINIST MOVEMENT, ETC.
I THINK IN EVERY ASPECT OF
AMERICAN LIFE, BEYOND THIS
COUNTRY BUT IN EVERY ASPECT OF
AMERICAN LIFE, YOU CAN SEE THE
EFFECTS OF THOSE DEFINING
MOMENTS.
IN MY OWN FIELD OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, THE DEFINING CASES
ARE NEW YORK TIMES VERSUS
SULLIVAN WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY
ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS AND THE
PENTAGON PAPERS CASE WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY ABOUT THE WAR IN
VIETNAM.>> THAT KIND OF
TRANSFORMATIONAL MOMENT I THINK
IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
I THINK WE ARE ENTERING SOME
KIND OF EXPERIENCES THAT ARE
LIKE THE VIETNAM WAR AND WHAT
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS
AGAINST.
WE ARE SEEING IN A VERY VISIBLE
WAY, I THINK WE ARE SEEING A
MANIFESTATION OF POLICIES AND
PRACTICES AND ATTITUDES AND SO
ON.
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
PROMPTED THE RESISTANCE TO THIS
AND EFFORTS TO TRY TO CHANGE
THE WORLD IN THE 1960S AND 70s
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN AGAIN
TODAY.
I SEE A VERY SHARP RELEVANCE TO
WHAT THEY PRODUCED 10 YEARS
AGO.
I'M SURE THEY HAVE THIS IN MIND
AT THIS MOMENT.
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
[ APPLAUSE ]SPIKE I THANK YOU
ALL FOR JOINING US, THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY FOR
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY.
TO CELEBRATE THE PREMIERE THIS
ASTOUNDING 10 PART, 18 HOUR
DOCUMENTARY ON THE VIETNAM WAR.
BUT ALSO TO SPEND TIME TALKING
ABOUT ISSUES THAT REALLY AFFECT
US PERSONALLY HERE ON CAMPUS.
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF THE MILITARY
AND ITS ENGAGEMENT, NOT ONLY
WITH COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY BUT
WITH CAMPUSES AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S REALLY A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE
WITH US KEN BURNS WHO IS
WITHOUT DOUBT ONE OF THE
GREATEST FILMMAKERS THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN.
HE HAS MADE US THINK, MADE US
CONFRONT OUR HISTORY AND TRULY
CONTRIBUTED TO SUBSTANTIVE
DIALOGUE WITHIN THIS COUNTRY.
HIS COLLABORATOR, LYNN NOVICK,
HAS WORKING WITH HIM  FOR 30
YEARS AND THEY ARE COPRODUCERS
OF THE VIETNAM WAR.
SHE ALSO HAS HER OWN PROJECTS,
A TWO-PART DOCUMENTARY ON THE
LIFE OF ERNEST HEMINGWAY.
>> I DON'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM
ME.[ LAUGHTER ]>> AND THE ONE
ON THE BARD COLLEGE PRISON?
IS YOUR MIKE WORKING?
AND MICHAEL K. HEANEY  WHO
ATTENDED COLUMBIA IN 1967
>> MIKE WAS A PLATOON LEADER IN
VIETNAM AND 65 AND 66.
IN THE FIRST CALVARY WHICH WAS
AMBUSHED, HE WAS THE LEAD
BALLOON -- LEAD PLATOON AND
MANY OF HIS MEN DIED IN THAT 20
HOUR BATTLE.
MIKE WAS BADLY WOUNDED, FLOWN
BACK TO THE U.S. AND
TRANSITIONED BACK INTO CIVILIAN
LIFE.
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS HE HAS
BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARY TEACHER
BUT MOSTLY ENGAGED WITH WORKING
WITH UTTERANCE AT ALL LEVELS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WOUNDED AND
THOSE SUFFERING FROM POST RACK
STRESS.>> MARK FRANKLIN IS A
CURRENT STUDENT AT THE SCHOOL
OF GENERAL STUDIES.
HE BEGAN AT COLUMBIA IN 2013
AFTER HAVING SERVED IN 2004 AS
A CAVALRY SCOUT WHICH HE TELLS
ME HIS ARMY RECON.
IN BAGHDAD, AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE HE EARNED A PURPLE HEART
AND BRONZE STAR.
HE ONCE AGAIN SAW ACTIVE DUTY
IN AFGHANISTAN IN 2006 WITH A
HELICOPTER HE WAS ON WAS SHOT
DOWN, HE WAS BADLY INJURED.
AFTER BEING MEDEVAC TO GERMANY
AND THEN TO WALTER REED WHERE HE
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT MEDICAL
ATTENTION, NUMEROUS SURGERIES,
HE WAS FINALLY ABLE TO REJOIN
THE CIVILIAN POPULATION.
HE IS MAJORING IN SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT.
WORKING ON GREEN URBAN
PROJECTS.
>> I'M GOING TO START BY ASKING
ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF THIS
PROJECT AND THE SIGNIFICANCE
THAT THEY BELIEVE IT HAS.
TO US HERE THEN WE WILL MOVE TO
LOOKING AT THREE SHORT CLIPS,
EACH I WILL PROVOKE
CONVERSATION AMONG THE
PANELISTS.
AT THE END, WE WILL MOVE TO
QUESTION FROM THE AUDIENCE.
THERE WILL BE MICROPHONES ON
EACH SIDE.
YOU HAVE YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
QUESTION THE PALACE.
>> KEN, GIVES A SENSE OF WHY
YOU BEGAN THIS PROJECT AND WHAT
YOU THINK IT WILL REALLY DO FOR
US.>> THANK YOU FOR INVITING
US.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ON THE SAME
PANEL WITH YOU AND MARK BUT
ALSO WITH OUR DEAR FRIEND MIKE
WHO WE HAVE GOTTEN TO KNOW FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AN EXTRAORDINARY HUMAN BEING.
WE WERE MAKING A FILM IN
HISTORY OF THE SECOND WORLD
WAR.
IT WAS GOING TO BE BROADCAST IN
THE FALL OF 2007.
AT THE END OF 2006, IT SEEMED
CLEAR AS WE LOOKED, COULD SEE
THE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL, WE LOOKED BEYOND AND
SAW AS THE MAJOR EVENT AFTER
THE SECOND WORLD WAR THAT WE
REALLY HAD TO DO VIETNAM AND I
SAID THIS TO LYNN AND SHE SAID
WERE PART  AND I SAID ALL THAT.
WE WERE COMMITTING OURSELVES TO
A DECADE OF ATTENTION TO
SOMETHING THAT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY FRAUGHT FROM
THAT PERIOD AND NOW.
SOMETHING WE DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
ME OF US ARE IN SILOS OF
ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY THAT TURNS
OUT TO BE WRONG, UPSIDE DOWN
AND BACKWARDS.
IT WASN'T A MOTIVATING FACTOR.
NONE OF OUR FILMS TRY TO POINT
ARROWS AT THE PRESENT AND SAY
ISN'T IT TOPICAL.
THIS FILM WAS FINISHED
EDITORIALLY BY THE END OF 2015
BEFORE IOWA CAUCUSES.
THE FILM IS, WE UNDERSTAND MARK
TWAIN IS SUPPOSED TO SEND MR.
HE DOES REPEAT ITSELF BUT IT
RHYMES.
THE FILM RHYMES WITH THE
PRESENT.
WE FELL IN 2006 -- WE FELT IN
2006 THERE WERE EVIDENT
CONNECTIONS AND WE FEEL IT
POTENTLY TODAY.
THE MEDIA IS LYING ABOUT HIM
AND MAKING UP STORIES,
ASYMMETRICAL WARFARE THAT
CONFOUNDS THE MILITARY.
A BIG DOCUMENT DROPS OF STOLEN
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL INTO THE
TOPICS BEER AND ACCUSATIONS A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN REACH DOWN
DURING THE TIME OF NATIONAL
ELECTION TO A FOREIGN COUNTRY
TO INFLUENCE THAT ELECTION.
ALL OF THAT IS JUST
AFTERTHOUGHTS AS WE BEGIN TO
RELEASE A SERIES IN WHICH WE
FELT WAS VERY IMPORTANT IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT VIETNAM, WE
HAD TO GET OUT OF THOSE
HARDENED SILOS AND MAYBE EVEN
OUT OF THE SAND ARE -- WE HAD
TO LOOK AT ALL SIDES TO
INTERVIEW SOLDIERS AND
CIVILIANS ON ALL SIDES AS WELL
AS A WHOLE MONOPOLY -- PANOPLY
OF AMERICANS.
MORE PORTLY, ALL THE GRADATIONS
IN BETWEEN.
WE CAN UNDERSTAND WE HAVE SEEN
SUBTLY IN WAR FILMS AND OTHER
FILMS WE HAVE DONE THAT THERE
CAN BE MORE THAN ONE TRUTH.
WE TRY TO CREATE A SPACE IN
WHICH THOSE COULD HAPPEN.
THE QUESTION YOU RAISED AT THE
BEGINNING ABOUT THE ACADEMY
IT'S PART OF A BINARY WORLD WE
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN.
EVERYTHING TO US IN THIS
COMPUTER AGE AND THIS MEDIA
CULTURE IS EITHER RIGHT OR
WRONG, BLACK OR WHITE.
WE ARE BESET BY THAT.
SO MANY OF THE DIVISIONS WE
EXPERIENCE WAS BORN IN THE
VIETNAM WAR AND HAVE ONLY GROWN
A METASTASIZED AND FESTER.
WE SORT OF FEEL IT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
IN THE WAKE OF THE SERIES WE
SPENT SO LONG PRODUCING THAT
MIGHT BE POSSIBLE TO RECONCILE
SOMETIMES SEEMINGLY OPPOSITE
THINGS AND UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH
THEY SHARE IN COMMON.
THAT IS THE SHORT HISTORY.
WE CAN SHOW YOU THE WHOLE FILM
IF YOU LIE.
>> ONLY 18 HOURS.[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE ARE EAGER TO SHOW CLIPS
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION.
WITH THE PRESIDENT SAID EARLIER
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR DURING THE TIME, I
AM BORN IN 1962.
WHEN I WENT TO COLLEGE, IT WAS
OVER.
THERE IS STILL SOME SMOKING
EMBERS BUT IT WAS BASICALLY
TAMPED DOWN.
FRUSTRATION AND DISINTEGRATION
OF SOCIAL ORDER WAS HAPPENING
FOR REASON.
IT WAS THE BUILDABLE PEOPLE
TAKING TIME TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE ARE REALIZING THEY WERE
SUBJECT TO THE DRAFT.
IT WAS A VERY HEALTHY
QUESTIONING OF OUR LEADERS WERE
NOT TELLING US THE TRUTH WHICH
SPIRALED INTO SOMETHING
FRIGHTENING AND DISTURBING.
BY 1970, STUDENTS TRYING TO
BURN DOWN THE ROTC BUILDING ON
A NUMBER OF CAMPUSES.
AS A RESULT, THIS IS ALL
HISTORY I LEARNED.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS FILM I HAD
A CHANCE TO GET TO MEET A GUY
WHO WAS THE WEST POINT CLASS OF
1945 AND BECAME AN ARMY
OFFICER, WORKED HIS WAY UP TO
COLONEL. HE HAD A VERY
DISTINGUISHED MILITARY CAREER
UP TO A CERTAIN POINT.
HE SAID HE THOUGHT IT WAS A
TERRIBLE THING THAT HAPPENED
WHEN THE CIVILIAN MILITARY
SCHISM HAPPENS AND ROTC WHEN
AWAY FROM COLLEGE CAMPUSES
BECAUSE WE WERE LEFT WITHOUT
OUR ARMY AND MILITARY BEING LED
BY PEOPLE WHO CAME FROM PLACES
LIKE THIS.
THAT WAS TRAGIC FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE HERE AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING IN THE INTERIM TO
REBUILD THAT CONNECTION BECAUSE
FOR ALL OF OUR COUNTRIES
NATIONAL SECURITY, WE NEED
PEOPLE COME TO PLACES LIKE THIS
TO BE WORKING IN OUR
MILITARY.>> WHY DON'T WE MOVE
TO THE FIRST CLIP.
I THINK THAT WILL SPARK A
SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE TERMS OF
PROTESTS, THIS IS A CLIP ABOUT
MAJOR PROTESTS NOT ONLY IN
FRONT OF THE PENTAGON BUT AN
EFFORT BY SOME TO MOVE INTO THE
PENTAGON.
[ VIDEO PLAYING ]
>> WE BEGAN TO SEE THEM AS
VICTIMS OF WAR.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I'M MICHAEL K. HEANEY .
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
ARE VETERAN.
JUST TO SEE.
GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
THANKS FOR COMING.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT PART
OF MY LIFE.
VIETNAM WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
PART OF MY LIFE.
I CAME BACK IN 1966.
PRETTY BADLY WOUNDED, WAS
TRYING TO SORT A LOT OF THINGS
OUT, NO ONE HAD INVENTED THE
TERM PTSD.
I WASN'T GETTING ANY TREATMENT
FOR SOME THINGS THAT WERE GOING
BADLY WRONG IN MY LIFE.
I THOUGHT I WOULD GO TO
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY FOR
SEMESTER.
IN THEIR SCHOOL OF GENERAL
STUDIES WHICH AT THAT TIME WAS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT IT IS
TODAY, HELPING A LOT OF
VETERANS.
IT WAS A PLACE WHERE I COULD GO
TO SCHOOL FOR SEMESTER BEFORE I
STARTED LAW SCHOOL.
THAT WAS REALLY MY FIRST
EXPOSURE TO THE RADICALISM AND
OPPOSITION TO THE WAR THAT HAD
TAKEN OVER ON A GREAT MANY
CAMPUSES.
RIGHT OUT HERE IN THE QUAD,
WHICH I HAVE IT BEEN TO IN 50
YEARS, I FIGURED THAT OUT ON
THE WAY OVER TODAY.
THERE WERE ALWAYS TABLES AND
GROUPS OF SELF IDENTIFIED
RADICAL STUDENTS ESPOUSING ONE
CAUSE OR ANOTHER.
THERE WAS ALWAYS A TABLE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE WAR IN
VIETNAM.
I WOULD INEVITABLY BE BE DRAWN
TO THAT TABLE AND WOULDN'T TELL
THEM WHO I WAS OR THAT I HAD
JUST BEEN BACK FROM VIETNAM.
WE WERE OFTEN TREATED POORLY
AND I DIDN'T WANT THEM TO KNOW.
I WOULD QUESTION THE GUY AND
WHAT EVIDENCE HE OR SHE HAD FOR
THE THINGS THEY WERE SAYING.
SOMETIMES THESE ENCOUNTERS
ENDED UP IN NICE LONG
DISCUSSIONS.
AND SOMETIMES THEY DIDN'T.
THAT WAS MY FIRST EXPOSURE.
I STARTED TO DEVELOP A FEELING
TOWARDS DISSENTERS AND DRAFT
DODGERS WHICH WAS BECOMING AN
INCREASING PATTERN.
THAT AND GOING TO LAW SCHOOL AT
A VERY RADICALIZED CAMPUS MADE
ME THINK HARDER ABOUT THE
VIETNAM WAR AND IF I HAD MADE A
BIG MISTAKE BY GOING.
THAT WAS THE INITIAL REACTION I
HAD.
>> I JUST WANTED TO ADD THE
DYNAMIC OF THE MOVEMENT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY FLUID WITHIN
OUR FILM AND DEVELOPS OUT OF
INTERNATIONALIST PROLIFERATION
COMBINED WITH CIVIL RIGHTS
COMBINED WITH LEGITIMATE MORAL
STUFF.
I GREW UP ON A COLLEGE IN ANN
ARBOR THAT WORLD BEING
DESCRIBED HERE WHICH IS
DOCUMENTED IN OUR FILM IN
ANOTHER SECTION INCLUDING THE
BRUTAL SUPPRESSION OF THAT
OCCUPATION HERE BY THE NEW YORK
CITY POLICE IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR FILM.
I WANT TO SAY THAT WHAT'S SO
INTERESTING IS HOW MUCH THE
RETURNING VETERANS BEGIN TO ADD
THEIR OWN SIGNIFICANT TRIBUTARY
TO AN ONGOING ANTIWAR MOVEMENT
THAT WAS CHANGING ALL THE TIME.
YOU CAN SEE IN THAT MARCH ON
WASHINGTON, THEY ARE SAYING
RING THE GIS HOME TO END THE
WAR NOW.
THEY SAW THAT AS AN IMPORTANT
CENTRAL PARTS.
WE INHERIT A GOOD DEAL OF THE
MISTREATMENT YOU ALSO FEARED
AND HAD HAPPENED.>> FOR MODERN
VETERANS, THE TERM VICTIM OF
THE WAR, THIS PHRASE IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN FROM THE VIETNAM
ERA.
THERE IS A DRAFT.
MOST OF THE VETERANS HERE JOIN
THE MILITARY WHEN WE WERE
ALREADY AT WAR.
WE MADE THAT AFFIRMATIVE
DECISION TO GO TO WAR.
THE IDEA OF BEING A VICTIM OF
IT ONLY COMES INTO VIEW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE DESIRE TO
EXTEND THE WAR FOR AS LONG AS
IT HAS BEEN.
THIS 16 YEAR CONFLICT WE ARE IN
PRESENTLY.
YOU START TO SEE THE
VICTIMIZATION I SUPPOSE OF
MILITARY PERSONNEL WHEN IT
COMES TO MULTIPLE DEPLOYMENTS,
OVER AND OVER GOING BACK.
MY FIRST WAS 15 MONTHS.
NOW, THEY ARE SHORTER BUT YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WITH EIGHT OR NINE
DEPLOYMENTS UNDER THEIR BELT.
THAT'S WHERE YOU BECOME A
VICTIM.
NOT SO MUCH BECAUSE OF THE WAR
BUT THE POLITICAL DECISION TO
CONTINUE ENGAGING IN THIS
CONFLICT FOR THE LINK THAT WE
HAVE.
>> OF THE STORY WE TRIED TO
TELL, THERE WAS AT TIMES, WHEN
IT CAME TO THINGS LIKE SHUNNING
SOLDIERS ARE GETTING AND
TARGETING RETURNING SERVICEMEN,
THE FOCUS NEEDED TO BE ON THE
POLICYMAKERS WHO ARE MAKING THE
DECISIONS TO PERPETUATE THE
WAR, TO KEEP IT GOING, TO NOT
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
TRUTH.
AND THAT DYNAMIC GOT DIFFUSED
WITH THE GENERAL FRUSTRATION
WITH EVERYTHING GOING ON.
THAT SENSE OF REVOLUTION, THERE
WAS A SENSE THAT WHAT WAS GOING
ON WAS DEVOLVING INTO SOMETHING
THAT WASN'T WORKING AND SOMEHOW
WE SEE IT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
SOLDIERS WERE CAUGHT IN THE
CROSSFIRE OF THAT.
ONE OF OUR VETERANS SAYS THAT
COMING HOME FROM VIETNAM, WAS
ALMOST AS DRAMATIC AS THE WAR
ITSELF.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WHICH WE
HAVE FOR A LONG TIME, WE
IMAGINE THAT WAR IS ABOUT THE
MOST DRAMATIC THING ONE CAN
IMAGINE.
THE IDEA THAT THE WELCOME HOME
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN THE WAY
RETURNING SOLDIERS FELT WAS
ALMOST AS DRAMATIC AS THE WAR
IS A PROFOUND THING TO THINK
ABOUT.
>> I THINK ALSO THAT MARK'S
EXPERIENCE AS ANOTHER ASPECT TO
THIS WHICH IS HUGELY IMPORTANT
WHICH IS, IN THE EARLY DAYS OF
THE VIETNAM WAR, IT WAS STAFFED
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
VOLUNTEERING.
YOU DID SEE THIS AS A CAUSE
LATER ON IN THE DRAFT -- THE
DROPS CAME -- THE DRAFT CAME
AND WAS MORE CONTENTIOUS.
WE LEARNED NOT TO BLAME THE
VETERANS AND WE CREATED AN ALL
VOLUNTEER ARMY.
THAT TAKES THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC'S SKIN OUT OF THE GAME.[
APPLAUSE ]THAT IS UNFORTUNATE
AND WE COULD TALK ABOUT A DRAFT
OR NATIONAL SERVICE.
WE HAVE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND WE
NOW HAVE A MILITARY COMMUNITY
1% OF THE POPULATION THAT
SUFFERS ITS LOSSES APART AND
ALONE FROM THE REST OF US.
THEREFORE, THERE IS NO EXERTION
OF WILL BY A LARGE GROUP OF THE
AMERICAN POLITY AGAINST
CONTINUING ON WITH THE WAR
PERMITS THIS INTOLERABLE,
UNCONSCIONABLE WAR CRIME OF
HAVING PEOPLE GO THROUGH SEVEN
OR EIGHT OR NINE DEPLOYMENTS.
IT'S ONE THING IF IT'S A WORLD
WAR AND YOU'RE IN WITH THE
DURATION, I GET THAT.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A PERPETUAL
WAR BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE A
PERPETUAL WAR, THE FACT THAT WE
RECTIFIED ONE ASPECT AND
CREATED AN EVEN BIGGER PROBLEM,
THAT SOMETHING WE OUGHT TO BE
ADDRESSING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REEDUCATING THE MILITARY WITH
THE ACADEMY OR VICE VERSA
BECOMES A POSSIBILITY FOR THE
REST OF US INSTEAD OF
CONVENIENTLY PUTTING IT OUT OF
OUR MINDS AND SAYING AT THE END
OF A SENTENCE, THANKS FOR YOUR
SERVICE BUT RATHER WELCOME HOME
AND WHAT CAN WE DO FOR YOU.
YOU BECOME PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WE HAVE A
POSSIBILITY AS A PUBLIC TO
REENGAGE AND REINVEST OURSELVES
IN THE ULTIMATE POLICY
DECISIONS THAT SEEM TO
PERPETUALLY SEND US INTO WAR.>>
WE, AS A COUNTRY, HAVEN'T BEEN
AT WAR SINCE VIETNAM.
OUR MILITARY HAS.
THE COUNTRY HASN'T.
THAT IS A KEY DIFFERENCE.
WE TALK ABOUT THE CIVIL,
MILITARY DIVIDE IN THIS
PERPETUATION OF STEREOTYPES OF
MILITARY PERSONNEL.
IT IS EXACTLY BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC HAS BEEN
TOTALLY INSULATED FROM THIS.
WE NOW HAVE A WHERE CAST OF
PEOPLE -- A WARRIOR CAST OF
PEOPLE WHO FIGHT FOR US.>> WHY
DON'T WE MOVE TO THE NEXT CLIP
WHICH IS COMING BACK HOME.
[ VIDEO PLAYING ]
>> THAT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY,
EXTRAORDINARILY POWERFUL PEACE.
THAT SENSE OF CONFLICT IS
SOMETHING YOU COULD GO THROUGH.
>> THIS NEXT MOMENT IS A NEAR
SUICIDE ERGO ONE OF THE THINGS
WE WANTED TO DO, WARS OFFER AND
INEVITABLY VILIFYING STUDY OF
HUMAN NATURE.
WE ARE DRAWN TO THE CONFLICT
AND WE PRESUME THAT CONFLICT IS
BETWEEN ARMIES AND IN FACT,
WHAT IS SO VERY CLEAR IN ALL
THE WARS, THE RATE -- THE VERY
IMPORTANT STORIES, THE
CONFLICTS, THE BATTLES, MIKE
HAS ALLUDED TO IT.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE, THE 80 OR
SO PEOPLE YOU MEET IN THE FILM,
PROFOUND PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
EMOTIONAL CHANGES IN THE COURSE
OF THIS.
IT MIGHT INFLUENCE THEIR
POLITICS.
WE WERE TRYING TO BE AS
CONSCIOUS AND AWARE OF THOSE
KINDS OF WARS AS WE WERE THE
OBVIOUS ONES ON THE BATTLEFIELD
WHICH WILL WE ARE NOT
NEGLECTING.
THEY ARE THERE.
THERE'S AN INTERESTING TENSION
WITHIN NARRATIVE BETWEEN THAT
INTERIOR AND EXTERIOR WARS.>>
AND WATCHING THE CLIP AND BEING
HERE, CONTEXT IS EVERYTHING.
I WAS REMINDED OF THE FACT THAT
EVEN TO THIS DAY, THERE IS
DEBATE ABOUT WHAT WAS SAID TO
SOLDIERS COMING HOME.
WERE PEOPLE SPIT ON, WERE THEY
NOT?
BOOKS HAVE BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S A CONVERSATION ONGOING
WITH EACH CAMP HAVING THEIR
LOCKED IN POSITION.
CLEARLY FROM THE VISUAL
IMAGERY, THERE IS AN ENORMOUS
TENSION AND CRITICISM DIRECTED
AT SOLDIERS.
I WAS REMINDED OF THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL WORDS OF WOMAN OUR
COLLEAGUE INTERVIEWED WHO WENT
TO COLUMBIA WHOSE NAME IS NANCY
BRAVERMAN.
YOU WILL SEE HER IN THE FILM AT
DIFFERENT POINTS.
SHE SAYS WE WERE KIDS TWO.
THE SOLDIERS WERE TEENAGERS AND
WE WERE TEENAGERS AND WHEN
YOU'RE THAT AGE, YOUR
EXPERIENCES ARE HEIGHTENED AND
EVERYTHING IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE WAS A LOT AT STAKE.
IN LOOKING BACK, SHE WAS ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE AND REGRET SOME OF
THE THINGS SHE SAID AND THAT
WERE DONE.
IN THE SPIRIT OF TRYING TO
AFFECT CHANGE, IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR US AS FILMMAKERS AND ANYONE
WATCHING THE FILM THAT PEOPLE
WHO PROTESTED THE WAR WERE
TRYING TO DO WHAT THEY THOUGHT
WAS THE RIGHT THING.
OUR FILM REALLY CALLS INTO
QUESTION, HOPEFULLY GET TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT DOES IT MEAN
TO BE A PATRIOT AND A COUNTRY
WE WORRY ARE NOT SURE EVERYONE
IS DOING THE RIGHT THING.
HOPEFULLY WE TRIED TO GIVE
ENOUGH SPACE IN THIS FILM FOR
DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS TO
HAPPEN.
>> ONE THING I REMEMBER VERY
WELL THAT HAPPENED RIGHT HERE,
I MIXER FRIDAY NIGHT TRYING TO
MEET SOMEONE TO GO OUT WITH AND
SOME GUY FIGURED OUT I WAS A
VETERAN AND I WAS RECENTLY
BACK.
HE PIPED UP AT ONE POINT,
GRABBED MY SHOULDER AND SAID
HOW DOES A DEAL TO OF BEEN
ATTACHED AND DEVOTED TO AN
ORGANIZATION WHOSE BUSINESS IT
WAS TO KILL WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
I WAS STUNNED.
MY INNER VOICE WAS SAYING, YOU
HAVE TO SPEAK UP, YOU HAVE TO
PUSH BACK.
I UNDERSTAND HOW HE FEELS.
SO I DID.
I SAID, I WAS THERE EARLY IN
THE WAR, GRANTED AMERICAN UNITS
WERE MORE TOGETHER.
FIRST CAVALRY AND FIRST
DIVISION WAS THE FIRST SENT
OVER.
IT WAS A GOOD MILITARY UNIT AND
PRACTICE GOOD TRADITIONAL
MILITARY VALUES WHICH INCLUDE
HONOR AND COURAGE AND FAIR
TREATMENT OF PRISONERS.
I NEVER SAW AN ATROCITY.
IMPACT ON A COUPLE OF
OCCASIONS, I ASKED MY MEN TO
TAKE RISKS SO THEY WOULD SHOOT
OR KILL THE WRONG PEOPLE BUT
THAT'S WHAT I BROUGHT BACK.
HE SAID SCREW YOU AND WALKED
AWAY.
THAT WAS THE KIND OF CONFLICT.
THEIR BOOKS WRITTEN ABOUT HOW
EXACTLY WERE VIETNAM VETERANS
TREATED.
I WAS MOSTLY TREATED OKAY.
PEOPLE WHO WERE ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED THE WAR TREATED ME
WELL.
BUT THERE WAS A LOT OF OTHER
STUFF AS WELL.
>> IS 68, THERE IS A PROTEST
HERE IN COLUMBIA.
THERE WAS A HYPER AWARENESS OF
THE WAR IN VIETNAM.
TODAY WE SUFFER FROM A
HYPERACTIVE AWARENESS.
I AM RARELY MET WITH ANY
ANIMOSITY ON COLUMBIA'S CAMPUS.
MOST OF THE TIME, IT'S
CURIOSITY.
PEOPLE JUST DON'T KNOW.
THEY DON'T HAVE IMMEDIATE
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT SERVE.
I WAS ASKED ONE TIME IN CLASS
WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO MURDER
WOMEN AND CHILDREN?
I DIDN'T HANDLE IT IS TO
PHONETICALLY AS YOU DO.
>> I HAVE IMPROVED THAT STORY
WITH AGE.[ LAUGHTER ]>> MY
RESPONSE WAS THAT THE KIDS WERE
DOUBLE POINTS AND AT LEAST I
ATE THEM AFTERWARDS.
THAT WAS NOT WELL-RECEIVED.
IT GOT ME VERY ANGRY.
IN RETROSPECT, I FEEL VERY
GUILTY ABOUT THAT REACTION.
IT'S A 19-YEAR-OLD STUDENT.
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT IS
TO BE A SOLDIER.
TO PROSECUTE A WAR AS AN
INDIVIDUAL IMPLEMENT OF WAR.
THERE ARE SO MANY LAYERS AND SO
MANY THINGS THAT GO INTO BEING
A SOLDIER THAT DON'T INVOLVE
KILLING.
TO EVEN ASSUME BECAUSE SOMEONE
HAS BEEN IN THE MILITARY, THEY
HAVE TAKE SOMEONE'S LIFE
BETRAYS A FUNDAMENTAL
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
MILITARY SERVICE IS.
>> ARCHIE BOTH HYPERAWARE ABOUT
WHAT CAN I CHAIR, WHAT CAN I
NOT SURE WHAT CONTEXT DO I
SHARE.
IS THAT TRUE?
MAYBE I'M WRONG.
SECOND MY HEART WAS BROKEN FOR
THE SAME REASON YOU SAW JOHN
MUSGRAVE.
WHEN I GOT TO LAW SCHOOL AFTER
YOUR SO, A LOT OF MY CLOSE
FRIENDS FIGURED OUT I WAS A VET
AND I WAS TURNING AGAINST THE
WERE GRADUALLY.
ONE OF THEM WAS AN ACTIVE
ANTIWAR DISSIDENT AND SAID YOU
HAVE TO LEAD OUR NEXT MARCH.
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND SAID, I
CAN DO THAT.
I DIDN'T COME BACK THAT LONG
AGO AND I LOST ON ONE DAY IN
TWO MINUTES 10 GUYS I HAVE
SPENT FIVE MONTHS LIVING WITH.
MOSTLY UNDEREDUCATED WORKING-
CLASS GUYS WHO I LEFT.
I CAME TO LOVE.
THEY GAVE IT ALL.
EVEN IF I END UP OPPOSING THE
WAR, I'M NOT GOING TO BREAK
FAITH WITH THEM.
YOU CAN SEE THE CONFLICT, THE
INATTENTION -- THE INNER
TENSION THAT PROVOKES.
>> I AM HYPERAWARE OF THE WAR.
THE CURRENT WAR.
THERE'S A CERTAIN FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PART OF
VETERANS, PARTICULARLY AT
COLUMBIA.
AS PART OF THE REASON WE ARE
HERE VETERAN INTEGRATION, WE
HAVE THE LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT
COME EVERY RECEIVE VALUES AND
BRING STUFF TO THE CLASSROOM
THAT YOUR TYPICAL UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT DOESN'T.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
TALK ABOUT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS I
WON'T TALK ABOUT.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, FOR THE
MODERN CAMPUS, IT'S JUST HAVING
AN INTERACTION.
A NORMAL INTERACTION WITH THE
VETERAN.
I AM HUGE STAR WARS FAN.
I LIKE SOCCER.
NORMAL GUY.
THAT'S VERY KEY TO VETERAN
INTEGRATION ON THE MODERN
CAMPUS.
>> ONE OF OUR MARINES SAYS WE
ARE NOT THE DOMINANT SPECIES
BECAUSE WE ARE NICE.
PEOPLE LIKE TO COMPLAIN
MILITARY TAKES YOUNG MEN AND
TURNS THEM INTO KILLERS.
HE SAID I WOULD ONLY SUGGEST
IT'S FINISHING SCHOOL.
WHAT WE DO IN THE ISOLATION OF
OUR MILITARY, NOT JUST IN
CIRCUMSTANCES OF ALL VOLUNTARY
MILITARY BUT HOW WE WON'T
CONFRONT OUR OWN CULPABILITY
WITH OUR PREDILECTION TOWARDS
VIOLENCE MAKES IT SUPER
DIFFICULT.>> WHY DON'T WE MOVE
TO THE FINAL CLIP WHICH
CAPTURES WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT
BECOMES ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
PROCESS WHAT THE EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN.
>> ALL OF THE PEOPLE YOU HAVE
MET IN THESE CLIPS, WE HAVE
ALREADY MET AND GOTTEN TO KNOW.
WE PROBABLY KNOW WHERE THEY
WERE TO HIGH SCHOOL.
WE KNOW THEIR EXPERIENCE AND WE
HAVE BEEN WITH THEM.
THIS CLIP PARTICULARLY AND ALL
THE OTHERS WE'VE SEEN ARE THE
CULMINATION OF MANY
INTERACTIONS WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE COME TO
KNOW LIKE FAMILY MEMBERS WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF THE NARRATIVE OF
THE SUM.
[ VIDEO PLAYING ]
>> FOR ME, THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY MOVING PIECE.
IT ALSO RAISES AN ISSUE THAT
HAS COME UP REGULARLY IN MY
DISCUSSION WITH STUDENTS WHO
ARE VETERANS.
IN THIS CLIMATE WHERE THERE IS
SUCH A DIVIDE, THE EFFORT TO
REALLY REACH OUT TO PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM PTSD CREATES AN
IMAGE OF THE RETURNING VETERAN
AS A TICKING TIME BOMB.>> THAT
IS A LEGACY OF VIETNAM.
THERE WERE SOLDIERS IN WORLD
WAR I WHO WERE NEVER FUNCTIONAL
AGAIN, WORLD WAR II AS WELL BUT
IT WASN'T DISCUSSED IN A
PRODUCTIVE WAY IN SOCIETY.
VIETNAM VETERANS DEMANDED
TREATMENT AND RECOGNITION AND
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT SOMETHING
WASN'T RIGHT.
AT EVERY VIETNAM VETERAN
SUFFERED PTSD.
THE VAST MAJORITY DO NOT AND
THE BEST MAJORITY ARE -- THE
VAST MAJORITY ARE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS.
WE HOPE OUR FILM UNDO -- CAN
UNDO THE STEREOTYPES.
WE HAVE TRIED TO ALSO RAISE THE
FACT THAT LINGERING EFFECTS OF
BEING AT WAR PREVAILED.>> EVEN
IN MY EXPERIENCE HERE, WHAT HAS
BEEN SO INCREDIBLY MOVING AND
IMPRESSIVE, EVEN THE STUDENTS
FOR WHOM THIS BECOMES AN ISSUE,
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH IT AND LEARN HOW
TO MANAGE IT.
MAYBE BECAUSE THEY HAVE CLEAR
GOALS THEY WANT TO ACHIEVE.
THEY SEE THEY HAVE A REAL
FUTURE.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE SEEN AS
THIS, ONCE YOU HAVE IT, YARD
DAMAGED GOODS FOR THE REST OF
HER LIFE.>> YOU SHOULD TALK
ABOUT THE WORK YOU DID WITH
BOB.>> THAT'S A GOOD DILEMMA.
TO THINK ABOUT.
WHAT IS PTSD?
IT'S A VAGUELY AND BROADLY
DEFINED MY CLINICALLY DEFINED
DIAGNOSIS.
IT IS SAID TO MIMIC OTHER
THINGS LIKE BIPOLAR DISORDER
AND ADDICTIVE ILLNESS AND IT
DOES SOMETIMES.
BUT IS DIFFERENT FOR EVERY
SOLDIER.
SOME SEEM TO GET THROUGH
DRAMATIC EXPERIENCE IS OKAY,
OTHERS DO NOT.
THE THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY IS
STILL DEBATES ENDLESSLY WHY
THIS HAPPENS IN A WORSE WAY TO
SOME THAN OTHERS.
I AM SURE I HAVE SUFFERED FROM
A LITTLE BIT.
I AM ALSO SURE I HAVE NOT
SUFFERED NEARLY AS MUCH AS MANY
OF MY FELLOW VETERANS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I, UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF BOB ROWE WHO WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER, THIS RETIRED
SPECIAL FORCES COLONEL, HE
STARTED A PROGRAM WITH OUTWARD
BOUND WHICH SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT AND THE VA
WHERE WE WOULD TAKE INTO THE
FIELD FOR WEEK ON AN OUTDOOR
EXPEDITION VETERANS DIAGNOSED
WITH PTSD AND IMPATIENCE IN A
VA HOSPITAL.
WE LEARNED OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS HOW BEST TO DO THIS.
SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT YOUR CRAZY
TO THINK -- TO TAKE A BUNCH OF
NUT CASES INTO THE WOODS.
IT WILL REPLICATE WHAT HAPPENED
TO THEM IN VIETNAM.
>> IT HELPED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WE DID THAT PROGRAM FOR 15
YEARS AND PUT 1000 VETERANS
WERE PATIENTS OF THE VA THROUGH
IT.
WHAT I WANT TO MAKE, THE POINT
I WANT TO MAKE, WHATEVER WAS
WRONG WITH ME AND THERE WERE
SEVERAL THINGS.
I DRANK WAY TOO MUCH.
I HAD FLASHBACKS THE ANGER ONE.
RANGE.>> WHATEVER I HAD, IF I
COULD DEAL WITH IT BEST BY
REACHING OUT TO OTHERS WHO ARE
WORSE OFF THAN I AND HELP THEM,
IT'S NOT ROCKET SCIENCE, IT'S
NOT A NEW TECHNIQUE.
IT'S PROBABLY AS OLD AS THE
HUMAN RACE IN WARFARE.
IT REALLY HELPED ME TO REACH
OUT.
I THINK THE ARMY AND OTHER
MILITARY BRANCHES DO MUCH
BETTER JOB OF TREATING VETERANS
WITH DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY,
PTSD AND OTHER AILMENTS THAT
ALL VETERANS SUFFER FROM.
SOME SUFFER MORE THAN OTHERS.
THAT'S MY THOUGHT ON THAT.>>
THE LINE THAT REALLY STRIKES ME
FROM THAT CLIP, EVERYONE CAME
HOME ALONE.
THERE'S NO FINALITY TO IT.
THERE ENDS UP BEING A VERY
DRAMATIC AND TO THE VIETNAM
WAR.
IN A LOT OF WAYS, NOT MUCH HAS
CHANGED.
YOU COME BACK, A LOT OF GUYS I
SERVE WITH REMAINED IN FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME.
I CAME BACK AND THERE WASN'T,
THERE WAS NO FANFARE WHATEVER.
WISHES PEOPLE OH, WELCOME BACK.
LEDGER LIE.
THERE'S STILL THAT SENSE OF
ISOLATION AND HIS PERSISTENT.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, JUST
BEING AWARE OF THE VAST AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST TO HELP VETERANS DEAL
WITH AND ANY NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT EXISTS IS GREAT.
YOU ALWAYS RUN THAT RISK OF
WHEN YOU PUSH TOO HARD ON
ISSUES LIKE THAT, YOU END UP
PAINTING ALL VETERANS WITH THIS
BROAD BRUSH.
IT'S A BALANCE AND IT'S ONE I
THINK WE ARE STILL WORKING TO
FIGURE OUT.
>> I AGREE, THE DIAGNOSIS OF
PTSD IS A WONDERFUL AND
IMPORTANT THING BUT IT HAS AN
ASPECT THAT IS NEGATIVE.
WE MADE A FILM ON THE SECOND
WORLD WAR AND THERE ARE MANY
MORE PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM PTSD
FROM THE SECOND WORLD WAR THAN
FROM VIETNAM JUST BY THE SHEER
NUMBERS.
THE KIND OF CULTURE IT WAS THE
SENSE OF AN AMBIGUITY ABOUT THE
CAUSE, THE LACK OF PROTESTS,
THE COMING HOME WITH GREAT
CELEBRATION WAS HUGELY
IMPORTANCE BUT IT NEVERTHELESS
WASN'T THERE.
HAVING MORE PORTED THINGS LIKE
THE SOLDIER'S HEART OR DIVINE
MADNESS OR SHELL SHOCK, GIVING
IT A DIAGNOSIS IS A BROAD
BRUSH.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE IT STUDIED
AND APPLIED IN OTHER PLACES.
IT STILL DOESN'T YET DO IT'S.
YOU ARE PRETTY POINTED IN THE
FILM, SOMETHING I WOULD NOT
GIVE AWAY IN 1000 YEARS, THE
LAST WORD OF OUR FILM.
TO HAVE MIKE'S EXPERIENCE OF
WHAT IN THE END YOU CAN DO WITH
IT.
LIKE AN ALCOHOLIC, YOU ARE AN
ALCOHOLIC FOREVER.>> THAT'S ME.
THERE'S NO HALF-LIFE TO THAT.>>
WHY DON'T WE BEGIN TO OPEN TO
QUESTIONS?>> THERE WILL BE
MIKE'S -- MICROPHONES ON EITHER
SIDE.
>> OF THE GROUND RULES ARE,
PLEASE BE EXTREMELY BRIEF
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET AS MANY
QUESTIONS IN AS POSSIBLE.
DON'T MAKE LENGTHY STATEMENTS.
IT SHOULD BE ONE QUESTION.
SECONDLY, WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
GET THROUGH EVERYONE'S I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE EARLY ABOUT
THAT.>> LET ME STARTS WHILE
PEOPLE ARE LINING UP ASKING A
QUICK QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW THE
MEDIA OPERATED DURING VIETNAM
IN CONTRAST TO IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN?
HOW HAS THAT HELP SOLIDIFY THIS
DIVIDE. IN VIETNAM, EVERYTHING
WE SAW COMBATS, WE SAW PEOPLE
BEING KILLED.
>> THERE ARE SEVERAL POINTS
THAT PLAY.
ONE IS THE ACCESS THAT
JOURNALISTS HAD DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR WHICH WAS
UNFETTERED AND UNCENSORED.
THERE WAS THE BEST JOURNALISTS
IN THE WORLD FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD CONVERGED ON VIETNAM TO
GET THE STORY.
200 JOURNALISTS WERE KILLED
DURING THE COURSE OF THE WAR TO
BRING US BACK IMAGES WE KNOW SO
WELL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD HAD IMAGES OF
THE WAR UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL
THAT THEY HAD NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
>> IT WAS LIKE EVERY NIGHT WAS
FULL OF BLOOD AND GUTS AND WHAT
WE WOULD CALL WAR PORN, IT
WASN'T THAT.
THERE WASN'T A GOVERNMENTS
NARRATIVE OF THE WAR WAS ABLE
TO BE CONSISTENT.
MUCH AS THE GOVERNMENT TRIED,
THERE IS CONSTANT FRUSTRATION
WE HERE PRESENT JOHNSON, NIXON
AND KENNEDY BEMOANING THE FACT
THAT THEY CANNOT CONTROL WHAT
THE PRESS IS SAYING AND THEY
DON'T LIKE THE COVERAGE IS
SLANTED.
IT'S NOT TELLING THE STORY THEY
WANT.
THINGS HAVE EVOLVED, ONE OF THE
LESSONS THE MILITARY LEARNED IS
NEVER TO GIVE THE PRESS THAT
ACCESS AGAIN.
WE DON'T SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITHOUT A LOT MORE RESTRICTION
ON IT AND THAT IS A HUGE EFFECT
ON WHAT WE EVEN KNOW.
OUR MEDIA LANDSCAPE, BUDGETS
AND RISKS.
IF THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS NOT
INVOLVED, WHAT IS THE
IMPERATIVE TO COVER THE WAR?
WHAT IS THE RELEVANCE TO THE
REST OF THE PEOPLE.>> TELL US
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
>> I AM WITH THE 01 ANNAPOLIS,
I'M A POLY SAY STUDENT.
-- POLITICAL SCIENCE STUDENT.
IN THE EARLY YEARS OF VIETNAM
THAT SEEMS IS A PRETTY
SUSTAINED BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS
IN WASHINGTON THAT WEIGHS IN
FAVOR OF MILITARY INTERVENTION.
MIGHT ALSO ACCOUNT FOR WHY F --
THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN HAS
SUSTAINED ITSELF ACROSS THREE
PRESIDENCIES NOW.
I WONDERED WHERE YOU THINK THE
OPPOSITION OR THE PLACE FOR
ANTI-INTERVENTION EXISTS TODAY
IN AMERICAN POLITICS?
>> I DON'T THINK AN EFFECTIVE
ANTIWAR OPPOSITION AT THE
HIGHEST POLITICAL LEVEL EXISTS
VERY MUCH?
THAT'S A BIG DISAPPOINTMENT TO
ME.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR IT IS
THE DIVIDE WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
VERY FEW OF TODAY'S HIGH-LEVEL
POLITICIANS, HIGH-LEVEL CABINET
MEMBERS, THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF
HAVE ANY MILITARY EXPERIENCE.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT AN
ARMY CAN AND CANNOT DO.
WHAT THEY ASK IT TO DO A LOT OF
IMPOSSIBLE THINGS.
I AM GLOOMY ABOUT THAT'S.
I THINK THIS IS AN ARENA WHERE
AVERAGE FOLKS LIKE YOU AND ME
CAN CONSTANTLY EXPRESS OUR
VIEWS BY CALLING OUR
REPRESENTATIVES.
I LIVE IN VERMONT, WE HAVE A
GOOD CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION
ON THAT ISSUE.
BOTH OUR SENATORS AND SINGLE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO WAR AS A GENERAL WAY
TO FIX PROBLEMS.>> I WOULD SAY
THE PROBLEM, UNLIKE AFTER WORLD
WAR II WE PROBABLY HAD HUNDREDS
OF CONGRESS PERSONS WHO HAD
SERVED AND BEEN A PART OF THE
ARMY AND PEOPLE WOULD LOOK
AROUND IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND
THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF
VETERANS WALKING AROUND.
THEY COULD TALK TO THEM AND
ASKED THEM ABOUT THE NEXT WAR
WE WERE CONSIDERING MY KOREA.
THAT NEEDS TO BE PUMPED UP.
I THINK AS A SINUS -- AS A
SOCIETY, WE CAN DO THAT.
IS NOT BE DONE AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS.>> WE DON'T EXIST IN A
CULTURE WHERE YOUR NEIGHBORS
ARE GETTING DRAFTED.
YOUR FAMILY ISN'T BEING
DRAFTED.
PEOPLE AREN'T GOING UP TO
CANADA.
THERE ISN'T A NATIONAL OUTCRY
ABOUT IT.
IT'S A THING THE MILITARY IS
DOING.
MEANWHILE WE ARE HERE AND WE
ARE OKAY WITH THAT.>> IT
DOESN'T PENETRATE TO THE
HIGHEST ECHELONS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THE OUTRAGES
AND THERE.>> I AM A FIRST-YEAR
GS THAT, FORMER ARMY COMBAT
CAMERA.
AS A STORYTELLER, I ALWAYS
START WITH, THREE WORDS ARE ONE
SENTENCE OF WHY I AM DOING
SOMETHING OR WHY AM TELLING A
STORY.
WHILE I HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY,
I WANT TO ASK YOU GUYS,
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF TAKEAWAYS AFTER
WATCHING THIS FILM.
IF THERE COULD BE ONE TAKE AWAY
WHETHER IT'S A THOUGHT, POINT
OF VIEW OR HOPE FOR THE FUTURE,
WHAT WOULD YOU ASK EVERYONE IN
THIS OR TO TAKE AWAY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO TOSS US TO
MAKE IT JUST A MINUTE.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TRIED
TO DO IS REPRESENT AS MANY
POINTS OF VIEW AS POSSIBLE.
IN LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IT'S
LIKE HER VETERANS TO COME HOME
AND NOT BE ABLE TO SPEAK
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A PLACE FOR
THAT.
HAS BEEN A GREAT EXERCISE IN
HUMILITY FOR US TO TALK TO
PEOPLE FROM EVERY LOCAL
PERSUASION.
PEOPLE WHO WON THE WAR, PEOPLE
WHO LOST THE WAR, A WHOLE RANGE
OF PEOPLE AND TO JUST BE
PRESENT AND LISTEN WITH AN OPEN
MIND.
AND NOT JUDGE AND REALLY TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PERSON
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO IS TRYING TO
TELL US ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE.
THAT IS NOT EASY.
YOU'RE ALWAYS SEEKING, WHAT
WOULD I DO?
THAT HAS BEEN LIFE ALTERING FOR
ALL OF US.
IT'S NOT A LESSON SPECIFICALLY
OF THE VIETNAM WAR BUT MORE HOW
TO UNDERSTAND IN THE CONTEXT OF
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY, THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
CHIME IN.>> LISTEN, COMPROMISE,
RECONCILE.
>> WHENEVER WE AS A COUNTRY OR
ON THE POINT OF DECIDING TO GET
INTO ANOTHER WAR, WE NEED TO
CALCULATE THE INEVITABLE
RECURRING HISTORICAL COSTS OF
WAR.
THEY ALWAYS HAPPEN.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE TO BE PAID.
THAT'S ALMOST NEVER DISCUSSED
AT THE BEGINNING.
THIS FILM LETS US LOOK
INTIMATELY AT DAMAGED HUMAN
BEINGS, AMERICANS, VIETNAMESE,
DAMAGED OR DEAD, DESTROYED
LANDSCAPES AND PROPERTY.
NONE OF THAT WAS IN MY MIND
WHEN I DECIDED TO GO OVER AND I
DON'T THINK IT WAS IN THE MINDS
OF ANY OF OUR LEADERS.
I CONGRATULATE LYNN AND KEN AND
THEIR TEAM  MAKING US LOOK AT
THE COSTS BEFORE WE GET INTO
ANOTHER.
>> I DEAN HAD SUBMITTED AN
EMAIL BOISTEROUSLY OBJECTING TO
OFFICES ON CAMPUS.
I'M WONDERING WHY THIS STILL
EXISTS AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
RECTIFY.
THE POINT OF THE EMAIL WAS AN
OBJECTION TO WHAT WAS TERMED
MILITARY POLICY.
>> TRANSGENDER MOSTLY.
>> I READ THE EMAIL, I WAS VERY
CURIOUS TO ME BECAUSE IT'S ONE
OF THOSE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT
PAINTING THE MILITARY WITH A
BROAD BRUSH& FUNDAMENTAL
MISUNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
MILITARY OPERATES.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION'S
DECISION TO BAN TRANSGENDER
FROM SERVING AS A POLITICAL
DECISION.
IT'S NOT A MILITARY DECISION.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING A BUNCH OF
GENERALS CAME UP WITH.
IT'S JUST STRAIGHT POLITICS.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE TO HEAR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO SAY IT'S
THE MILITARY HAS A BAN ON IT.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S A POLITICAL BAN.
PARTICULARLY WITHIN JACK, --
THE MODERN MILITARY DOES A VERY
GOOD JOB OF THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, THE REALITY IN
WHICH WE OPERATE, WE OPERATE
UNDER POLITICAL WHIMS.
THE MILITARY RESPONSE WASN'T,
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ARE BANNED,
IT'S WE ARE GOING TO DRAG OUR
FEET AND PLUMMETING THE POLICY
AND HAS BEEN A VERY PUBLIC
DRAGGING OF FEET ON THE POINT
OF THE MILITARY.
IS DISAPPOINTING TO HAVE A DEAN
OF THE LAW SCHOOL WHO
UNDERSTANDS THESE SEPARATIONS
OF POWERS AND HOW THE
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS STILL WANT
TO PAINT THE MILITARY AS A
DISCRIMINATORY ORGANIZATION.
>> IN A BROADER STROKE, THERE
IS A SIN TO CERTAINTY.
NO INSTITUTION IS IMMUNE TO IT.
WE OUGHT TO BE ON GUARD ABOUT
THE CERTAINTY THAT COMES FROM
PEOPLE'S POINTS OF VIEW AND
THAT'S PART OF THE SILOS OF
TALKING ABOUT.
THESE ARE NOT HARDENED SILOS
THE MILITARY NECESSARILY IS IN
BUT ALL OF US ARE IN.
WHENEVER WE FIND OURSELVES
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN ABOUT AN
HISTORICAL EVENT, I WOULD JUST
INVITE YOU TO REALIZE THERE IS
THE OPPOSITE THAT IS ALSO TRUE.
WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF THAT.
THE ACADEMY FOR HIS PART HAS TO
LET GO SOME VERY EASY SIMPLE
TROPES THAT DOES WHAT YOU DO IN
WAR WHICH IS YOU OBJECT IF I
THE ENEMY AND YOU MAKE THE
OTHER IN HUMAN.
IN DOING THAT, EVERYONE IS VERY
SIMPLE IT'S ALL VERY CLEAR AND
IT PERMITS YOU TO DO THE
FIGHTING AND IT'S ALSO HUGELY
DANGEROUS.
THE PTSD SMALL ASPECT IS HOW DO
YOU RETURN TO A WORLD IN WHICH
YOU NOW MADE SOMETHING VERY
ELEGANTLY SIMPLE AND IT'S NOT
THAT AT ALL.
IT NEVER WAS THAT.>> MY NAME IS
JAY ALBAN.
I'M A RETIRED OFFICER AND
AUDITOR AT THE COLLEGE.
THE CIVILIAN ANTIWAR MOVEMENT
IN VIETNAM TOOK GREAT ATTENTION
AND INSPIRATION FROM THE G.I.
ANTIWAR MOVEMENT.
FROM THE CALL SHE SHOPS TESH
COFFEE SHOPS AND NEWSPAPERS AND
HALF 1 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
FORMED AWOL COMMUNITIES IN
CANADA AND SWEDEN.
WE ABLE TO COVER THAT AND CAN
YOU SAY WHAT YOU ASSESS WHAT IS
IMPORTANT OF THE G.I.
ANTIWAR MOVEMENT?
>> WE CHART THE EVOLUTION OF
SOLDIERS BECAME MORE ADAMANTLY
OUTSPOKEN AGAINST THE WAR.
THAT'S PART OF THE STORY WE
TELL.>> WITH THE COFFEEHOUSES
AND NEWSPAPERS AND ACTIVITIES
AND THROWING OF METALS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> YOU WILL SEE A GOOD DEAL OF
THAT IN THE FILM.>> TO KNOW HOW
MUCH OF AN INFLUENCE OR VALUE
THAT WAS.
>> WATCH THE MOVIE?
WE DON'T WANT TO BOIL IT DOWN
WE CAN SLING HERE BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY PART OF THE STORY.
>> ONE OF THE MOST
REPREHENSIBLE MEMO SUCCUMB OUT
OF THE WAR IS A SECRET MEMO
THEN MADE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
REASON WHY WE ARE IN VIETNAM,
70% TO SAVE FACE.
20% TO CATARACT THE CHINESE AND
10% TO HELP THE VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE.
THE PUBLIC RELATIONS IS EXACTLY
THE OPPOSITE WITHOUT EVER
ADMITTING TO SAVING FACE.
WE WOULD BE TERRIBLY REMISS IF
WE COULD QUANTIFY WHAT THE
EFFECTS OF ANY GIVEN THING WAS.
WE LIKE TO TRY TO PUT AS MANY
OF THESE GIVEN THINGS IN AND
UNDERSTAND OVER TIME THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST SAW THE WAR WAS SOMETHING
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN INTO,
THEN SOMETHING THAT WAS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD GET OUT OF
AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN THEN SEND
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD AND
DRIVEWAY.
WE CHART THAT AND THERE'S LOTS
OF DIFFERENT REASONS WHY.
BRING HOME A COFFIN OF YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL QUARTERBACK IS A
REALLY BIG THING IN PARTS OF
THIS COUNTRY.
LOSING FRIENDS.
HAVING YOUR SON ELIGIBLE FOR
THE DRAFT WHEN THE DEFERMENTS
WERE ENDED AND IT'S JUST A
LOTTERY.
THESE ARE THE THINGS.
THE ACTIVISM OF PEOPLE,
SOLDIERS INCLUDED HERE AND IN
CANADA AND ACROSS IS SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
WE WOULD BE AS FRAUDULENTLY
REMISS IF WE WERE TO SOMEHOW
QUANTIFY IT AS IT IS IN THIS
MEMO.>> I'M A PSYCHIATRIST AT
THE MEDICAL CENTER AND IN THE
NAVY RESERVES.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
THAT SPANS THE HISTORY OF
FILMMAKING FROM THE CIVIL WAR
TO THE WORLD WAR II FILMS TO
THIS ONE.
THERE'S A FASCINATING EVOLUTION
OF EXPLORING THE AMERICAN
CHARACTER.
BASED ON WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED
OVER THAT TRILOGY IN SOME
SENSE, WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD
BE PART OF THE DIALOGUE WE
ENGAGE WITH?
WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS FOR US
IF WE WERE TO UPPER THESE TYPES
OF INTERVENTIONS GOING
FORWARD?>> WHAT A WONDERFUL
QUESTION.
WITH REGARD TO THE FACT THAT
SOME REASON, HUMAN BEINGS GO TO
WAR.
WE ALSO FORGET THE COST OF WAR.
THEY ROMANTICIZE AND SENTIMENT
LIES.
THIS IS THE WORST WAR EVER.
THE GREATEST CATACLYSM IN HUMAN
HISTORY AND KILLED 60 MY PEOPLE
AND IS A GOOD WAR?
WOULD THAT ONLY COMES IN
VIETNAM BECAUSE IT WASN'T SO
GOOD.
THE CIVIL WAR IS SMOTHERED WITH
A GALLANT, BLOODLESS STUFF ON
THE LOST CAUSE AND NOT WHAT IT
WAS REALLY ABOUT, SLAVERY.
AND ALL OF THE WARS, I FIND AN
UNBELIEVABLE, UNCANNY,
DISAPPOINTING AND AT TIMES
EXHILARATING SIMILARITY BETWEEN
WHAT'S GOING ON PARTICULARLY
VIETNAM AND CIVIL WAR.
THE OPPOSITIONAL STUFF IS VERY
SIMILAR.
TO ME, I JUST THINK HUMAN
BEINGS HAVE TO BE REMINDED
SOMETIMES.
OF WHAT THE COST IS.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT WHEN THE
CIVIL WAR SERIES CAME OUT IN
LATE SEPTEMBER 1990, A MONTH
AND A HALF EARLIER, SADDAM
HUSSEIN HAD INVADED KUWAIT.
BY THE TIME WE CAME TO OUR
NATIONAL BROADCAST, SOMETHING
LIKE 85% OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS, THE
MARINE BARRACKS IN BEIRUT,
HADN'T BEEN AT WAR IN AN
AWFULLY LONG TIME WERE SUPER
EXCITED TO GO TO WAR.
85% OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC WAS
ACTUALLY CHOMPING AT THE BIT.
AFTER THE CIVIL WAR PLAYED
WHICH IS JUST A STORY AND BLACK-
AND-WHITE PHOTOGRAPHS OF
AMERICANS KILLING OTHER
AMERICANS, THAT APPETITE THE
CLIENT BY QUARTER.
WISH IT WAS MORE.
WE CONSIDER THAT OUR BEST VIEW
-- REVIEW.
IF WE ARE GOING TO DO THIS, ALL
OF THIS DISCUSSION, WE OUGHT TO
HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME AND NOT
JUST TRUST THE WARRIOR CLASS TO
DO THE WORK FOR US.
WE ALSO HALF TO HAVE -- HAVE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS WE JUST
DON'T HAVE BECAUSE WE ARE
EASILY WHIPPED UP INTO A FRENZY
OF THE SALACIOUS POSITIVE
ASPECTS OF WHAT WAR CAN DO.
WE CAN WIN, THEY WILL BE DEAD.
WILL BE GOOD.
I AM CONTINUALLY SHOCKED BY OUR
SPECIES OF WARMING DESIRE TO
HEAD IN THAT DIRECTION AT THE
DROP OF A HAT.
>> I DID MY PHD THESIS ON THE
EFFECT OF BEING IN A CIVIL WAR
ON A GROUP OF UNION'S -- UNION
SOLDIERS ARE HEAVILY ENGAGED.
THE FIRST THING I LEARNED,
NOBODY HAS CARED ENOUGH TO
RESEARCH THIS.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
MARKETING MAX, THE COLONELS AND
GENERALS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE AVERAGE SOLDIER NORTH OR
SOUTH IN THE CIVIL WAR AFTER HE
CAME BACK FROM WAR.
WHAT I TRY TO DEMONSTRATE,
THESE MEN CAME BACK AND WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY BROKEN,
DISEASED, BADLY WOUNDED, IN
PAIN MEN. IF THEY LIVED VERY
LONG AT ALL, THEY DIED THAT
WAY.
THE HELP THEY GOT WAS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, CHURCHES, WIVES.
THERE WAS SUCH ENTHUSIASM GOING
INTO THAT WAR, BOTH SIDES ARE
SURE THEY'RE GOING TO WIN
QUICKLY.
THEY WOULD COME OUT AND WATCH
BATTLES AT THE BEGINNING.
LOOKOUT TURNED OUT.
IT TURNED OUT LIKE EVERY WAR,
WITH BROKEN PEOPLE AND BROKEN
HEARTS AND THAT THE COST WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND AND TALK
ABOUT BEFORE WE GET INTO WAR.>>
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY TRUSTEE.
IN MAKING A FILM, WE GET A
SENSE THEY LOOK AT THE PRISM OF
CIVIL WAR, WORLD WAR I, WORLD
WAR II, CURRENT CONFLICTS.
I HEARD LITTLE ABOUT KOREA.
AND HOW THAT MAY HAVE INFORMED
YOU, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
CURRENT SITUATION IN KOREA
WHICH MAY WELL BE THE NEXT
WAR.>> WE FINISHED OUR FILM IN
2015.
BEFORE THE IOWA CAUCUSES AND
BEFORE WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
I WOULD SAY, OF ALL OF THE WARS
THAT INFORM OUR FILM, SO MANY
OF OUR VETERANS PARENTS BOUGHT
IN THE SECOND WORLD WAR AND YOU
CAN FEEL IT BEHIND THEIR
MOTIVATIONS AND THEIR DRIVES
EARLY ON.
WE ARE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
POLITICAL COMMENTARY.
WE ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
ANSWER A SIMPLE QUESTION, WHAT
HAPPENED.
THAT MEANS -- OUR FILM BEGINS
IN 1858, PASSES THROUGH THE
KOREAN WAR, IT'S USUALLY
IMPORTANT MOMENT FOR WHY WE ARE
IN VIETNAM AND WE SAY SO.
THE FIRST EPISODE ENDS AND THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE
SUNDAY NIGHT.
IT ENDS WITH THE KENNEDY'S
INAUGURATION.
WE ARE PLOWING FORWARD FROM
THERE.
THOUGH IT ENDS NOW, THE LAST
BIT OF GRANULAR HISTORICAL DATA
IS THE FALL OF SAIGON.
WE TRIED TO COME TO TERMS WITH
A VAST AMOUNT OF NEW
INFORMATION AVAILABLE FROM NEW
SCHOLARSHIP AND TESTIMONY OF
THE EXTRAORDINARILY COURAGEOUS
PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT IN IT OR WHO
FOUGHT AGAINST IT WHO POPULATE
OUR FILM.>> THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS.
I AM A PROFESSOR AT THE POLICY.
IN THE OPENING -- ANTHROPOLOGY.
-- IN THE OPENING, PART OF THE
PROJECT OF THIS FILM WAS
TELLING IT FROM VARIOUS
VIEWPOINTS.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU SAID,
ALMOST AS AMERICANS TALK ABOUT
VIETNAM ALMOST ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT THE AMERICANS.
IN FACT, I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE
TO SEE IT, TELLING THE STORY
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
VARIOUS VIETNAMESE PUBLIC SEEMS
KEY.
I QUESTION IS NOT TODAY.
ONE CAN SAY WE BARELY TALK
ABOUT THE WARS IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
BUT WHEN WE DO, WE ONLY TALK
ABOUT THE AMERICANS.
I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHY THE THREE
CLIPS YOU CHOSE TO PRESENT WERE
ALL AMERICANS.
>> THE THEME OF THIS EVENT WAS
A CIVILIAN MILITARY DIVIDE.
THAT'S IT WE WERE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT.
WE COULD HAVE SPENT AN EQUALLY
EQUAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
VIETNAMESE PERSPECTIVE.
YOU HAVE TO SEE THE FILM.
OUT OF 18 HOURS, WE CAN ONLY
PICK A FEW CLIPS.
EVERYWHERE WE GO WE TALK AT
GREAT LENGTH ABOUT WHY WE
WANTED TO INCORPORATE AS MANY
ENEMIES PERSPECTIVES AS
POSSIBLE.
>> YOU CAN BLAME ME.>> EPISODE
THREE TONIGHT, IT WILL
PARACHUTE RIGHT INTO THAT
EXPERIENCE.>> SINCE YOU RAISED
IT, IT SPEAKS TO THIS QUESTION
ABOUT HOW WE REMEMBER WARS AND
WHAT MIKE WAS SAYING ABOUT HOW
WE JUST JUMP IN WITHOUT KNOWING
THE COST.
IN OUR MANY TRIPS TO VIETNAM,
THAT HAS BEEN A RECURRENT THEME
THERE, EVEN MORE SO THAN HERE.
THE VIETNAMESE LOST 3 MILLION
PEOPLE OUT OF 30 MILLION.
MILLION SOLDIERS ON THE WINNING
SIDE AND TWITTER FOR 2000 ON
THE LOSING SIDE AND YOU CAN ADD
UP THE REST.
IN VIETNAM TODAY, THE
CONVERSATION DOESN'T HAPPEN
ABOUT THE WAR AT ALL EXCEPT AS
SORT OF A GRAND NARRATIVE WITH
NO PEOPLE IN ITS.
WHEN YOU WENT THERE AND SAID WE
WANT TO MAKE A FILM ABOUT THE
HUMAN EXPERIENCE FROM ALL
SIDES, WE WERE WELCOMED BECAUSE
THAT CONVERSATION HASN'T BEEN
HAPPENING.
THERE IS AN INTEREST NOW IN
RECKONING WITH THE TRUE COST OF
THE WAR FOR THEM AND WE HAVE
SOME QUITE REVELATORY TESTIMONY
FROM VERY -- FOR MANY DIFFERENT
VIETNAMESE, SOLDIERS AND
CIVILIANS ABOUT HOW DOES ONE
MAKE MEANING OUT OF A TRAGEDY
ON THE SCALE.
THIS THE FILM HAS BEEN SUBTITLED
AND IS AVAILABLE TO BE WATCHED
IN VIETNAM.
WE HAVE ALMOST AS MANY STREAMS
IN VIETNAM AS WE HERE.
>> I REALLY LOVE YOUR FILMS,
THEY HAVE HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON
ME.
I WAS CURIOUS GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THIS TOPIC AT HAND HAS
MUCH LESS CONSENSUS THAN ON THE
SUBJECT OF SOME OF YOUR OTHER
FILMS, HOW WOULD YOU GO ABOUT
DECIDING DEDICATING SCREEN TIME
TO CERTAIN VIEWPOINTS.
>> FOR THE MOST PART, OR
APPARENTLY THERE IS CONSENSUS
ABOUT STUFF.
PRESS THE SURFACE OF ALL THAT
AND IS NOT CONSENSUS.
YOU ARE RIGHT FOR THE ARGUMENT,
THERE IS NO CONSENSUS.
WHAT HAS DEVELOPED SINCE WE
DECIDED TO IGNORE OR BE CERTAIN
ABOUT OUR POSITION, WAITED MORE
TO ARGUMENT THE FACT.
READ ONLY TAKEN OUT OUR PITCHER
IN THE SIX BUT AT THE SEVENTH.
BUT YOU DIDN'T AND YOU LOST.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DRAW FROM
20 OR 30 DIFFERENT SCHOLARS,
MORE IF YOU DIDN'T COUNT THE
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T COME TO OUR
NEW HAND SURE -- NEW HAMPSHIRE
EDITING ROOM.
WE CAN DISTILL AND APPREHEND A
SCHOLARLY CONSENSUS ABOUT
THINGS.
WE HAVE SPENT THE 10 YEARS
DOING THAT.
I'M NOT SAYING WE ARE OFFERING
A VERSION OF WHAT HAPPENED.
WE TRIED TO CREATE A SPACE IN
WHICH THAT LACK OF CONSENSUS
TURNED ON ITSELF IN A POSITIVE
WAY AND PERMIT US TO SEE THE
WAR THAT EVERYONE'S VIEW HAS
VALIDITY AND WE WILL NOT MAKE
ANYBODY WRONG HERE BECAUSE
CONSENSUS IS ABOUT SAYING WE
BELIEVE ONE AND ONE IS TO.
ASH TWO..
I WOULD ASK EVERYONE HERE WHO
HAS BEEN INFLUENCED BY ART,
RELATIONSHIP OR FAITH OR BY
WHATEVER, ONE AND ONE CAN EQUAL
THREE AND THE REASON WHY ALL OF
US ARE HERE IS WE ARE LOOKING
FOR THAT MOMENT WHEN ONE AND
ONE BECOMES THREE.
WE HAVE RESOLVED OURSELVES OF
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO IN A
BORING AND WROTE WAY CLAIMANT
ORTHODOXY ABOUT VIETNAM AND
PERMITTED VIETNAM TO TALK TO US
WITH ALL ITS VOICES.>> I'M A
VISITING HISTORY PHD STUDENT.
MY QUESTION IS FOR MIKE AND THE
PANEL, I WAS IN YOUR VIETNAM
WAR TRINITY COLLEGE COURSE 18
MONTHS AGO AND I WAS CURIOUS
-->> YES, IRON YEAR.
>> I'M CURIOUS I APPROACHED THE
TASK WITH THESE TWO DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES OF BEING A VETERAN
AND BEING A TRAINED ACADEMIC
HISTORIAN AND MORE BROADLY HOW
YOU CAN MEDITATE ON THE PLACE
OF THE VETERANS PERSPECTIVE IN
ACADEMIC HISTORY.>> FIRST, HOW
DID YOU EVALUATE ME FOR THE
COURSE?[ LAUGHTER ]>> AND WHEN
ARE YOUR OFFICE HOURS?>> THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION.
DANCER BRIEFLY, I DECIDED TO
TRY NOT TO MAKE THE COURSE
ABOUT ME AND TO KEEP MY WAR
STORIES AT A VERY LOW LEVEL.
OVER TIME, I INCHED INTO
TELLING MORE MORE OF MY OWN
STORIES TO ILLUSTRATE WHAT I
THOUGHT WERE HISTORICALLY
RELEVANT AND IMPORTANT THINGS
TO LEARN.
AS YOU REMEMBER, I GOT SOME
ENCOURAGEMENT FOR THAT FROM THE
STUDENTS.
I ASKED WHICH LIKE TO HEAR A
FULLER VERSION OF MY WAR STORY,
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IN CLASS
BUT IF YOU WANT TO MEET ME AT
SIX THIS EVENING AND HAVE
PIZZA, I WILL TELL YOU AND YOU
CAN ASK WHATEVER QUESTIONS YOU
WANT.
IS NEVER AN EASY THING FOR ANY
ACADEMIC TO KEEP HIMSELF OR
HERSELF OUT OF WHAT THEY'RE
TEACHING.
THE CLASS WAS VERY RESPECTFUL
AND CURIOUS.
ENDED UP THINKING THEY WANT TO
HEAR SOME OF THE STORIES
BECAUSE THE STORIES ARE
IMPORTANT.
CAN AND LYNN ARE LIVING
EMBODIMENTS OF THAT.
>> SPIKE ON THE RECENT GRADUATE
-- I AM A RECENT GRADUATE.
OR YOUR HOPES AND THE LESSONS
WE WOULD GAIN FROM THE SERIOUS?
IT'S A THICK ABILITY TO CURRENT
DAY SITUATIONS AND ALSO ARE
THERE LIMITATIONS?
TO THE APPLICABILITY TO OUR
MODERN VETERANS AND HOW
DIFFERENT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE?>> I WILL LET LYNN ANSWER
THAT.
HISTORY IS THE BEST TEACHER.
IN ARMS YOU IN SPECTACULAR WAYS
TO CONFRONT AND DEAL WITH THE
PRESENT.
HISTORY DOES NOT REPEAT ITSELF.
MARK TWAIN IS CORRECT.
WE ARE NOT CONDEMNED TO REPEAT
WHAT WE DON'T REMEMBER.
ECCLESIASTES MAY HAVE A BETTER,
WET HAS BEEN WILL BE AGAIN,
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE WILL BE DONE
AGAIN, THERE'S NOTHING NEW
UNDER THE SUN WHICH SUGGEST
HUMAN NATURE DOESN'T CHANGE.
WE WILL, IT'S A PROPOSES ITSELF
WE CAN PERCEIVE PATTERNS OF
MOTIFS AND HEAR THE RHYMES AND
ECHOES THAT PERCEIVE AND FEEL
ALMOST PROBABLY THE GHOSTS.
THERE IS A STRONG LIMITATION TO
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT.
IN FACT, THE GREATEST WITTICISM
ABOUT WAR WHEN YOU ABSTRACT
DICK IS THAT YOU ALWAYS FIGHT
THE CURRENT WAR WITH WHAT YOU
LEARNED FROM THE LAST WAR.
THAT IS TRUE OF HUMAN BEINGS IN
RELATIONSHIPS AND IN LIFE.
I WOULD CAUTION ABOUT A DIRECT
ONE-TO-ONE AS INCREDIBLY
DAZZLING AS A LIST OF
SIMILARITIES MAY BE, THEY ARE
JUST THAT, SIMILARITIES.
THE ENGAGEMENT WITH THAT PASSED
TEACHES A GREAT DEAL ABOUT HOW
TO NEGOTIATE A COMPLICATED
PRESENCE.
>> THAT IS A WONDERFUL WAY TO
END OUR CONVERSATION.
>> THANK YOU ALL.
[ APPLAUSE ]>> THANK YOU CAN,
THANK YOU LYNN, THANK YOU MIKE,
THANK YOU MARK.
I HOPE THIS WILL STIMULATE
INCREASED CONVERSATIONS BUT OUR
GUESTS HAVE TO BE WHISKED TO AN
EVENT.
ENJOY THE REST OF YOUR DAY,
THANK YOU, THIS IS GREAT.